Welcome back to The David Pakman Show, I am
Jesse Delmore, out of work stunt double for
Jim Gaffigan Show.
Yesterday, something happened that we've been
waiting for for many years, and that is an
infrastructure bill to pass.
During the Trump administration, it seemed
like infrastructure week was every week in
perpetuity.
Materialize into nothing.
And we passed less than we wanted, less than
we need, certainly less than we deserve, but
better than nothing.
Reading from this New York Times article entitled
Senate Passes One Trillion Dollar Infrastructure
Bill and even Biden a bipartisan win.
The approval came after months of negotiations
and despite deficit concerns, reflecting an
appetite in both parties for a long awaited
spending package.
So the vote ended up being 69 to 30, which
is telling that they were able to get nearly
20 Republicans on board.
Even Mitch McConnell, in fact, the Senate
gave overwhelming bipartisan approval on Tuesday
to a one trillion dollar infrastructure bill
to rebuild the nation's deteriorating roads
and bridges and fund new climate resilience
and broadband initiatives, delivering a key
component of President Biden's agenda.
The vote, 69 to 30, was uncommonly bipartisan.
The yes votes included Senator Mitch McConnell
of Kentucky, the Republican leader, and 18
others from his party who shrugged off increasingly
shrill efforts by former President Donald
J. Trump to derail.
It is the last part of that sentence because
that was indeed the M.O. has been the M.O.
of Trump and the Republicans for a long time.
I am still weary of what is happening.
Wari, excuse me of what's happening here.
What is to take place?
What's the what Machiavellian motivations
do they have for overwhelmingly or for Republicans?
It's overwhelming support of this bill.
The historic investment in infrastructure
is what I believe you, the American people
want what you've been asking for for a long,
long time, Mr. Biden said from the White House
as he thanked Republicans for showing a lot
of courage.
Because in today's day and age, it is courage
to support an infrastructure bill that is
desperately needed as our bridges and our
tunnels and our roadways and our infrastructure
is literally crumbling.
Mr McConnell, who publicly declared that his
priority was stopping the Biden agenda, said
in a statement that, quote, I was proud to
support today's historic bipartisan infrastructure
deal and prove that both sides of the political
aisle can still come together around common
sense solutions.
If it were coming from anybody other than
Mitch McConnell, I might believe it.
The measure faces a potentially rocky and
time consuming path in the House, where Speaker
Nancy Pelosi and a majority of the nearly
100 member progressive caucus had said they
will not vote on it unless the Senate passes
a separate, even more ambitious three point
five trillion dollar social policy bill this
fall that could put the infrastructure bill
on hold for weeks, if not months.
And the the method by which they intend to
press the Senate to pass that three point
five trillion dollar appropriation is through
reconciliation where they won't need.
They could bypass the filibuster.
They could bypass Republican obstructionism.
Here is a little larger context, a little
longer context of what Joe Biden said in his
speech.
Speaker 3: First of all, I want to thank a
group of senators, Democrats and Republicans,
for doing what they told me they would do.
The death of this legislation was mildly premature,
as reported.
They said they're willing to work in a bipartisan
manner and I want to thank them for keeping
their word.
That's just what they did.
After years and years of infrastructure week,
we're in the cusp of an infrastructure decade
that I truly believe will transform America.
Speaker 1: So it was a good day for the country,
certainly a good day from an agenda agenda
standpoint for President Biden.
There was another side, though.
That is the side of Mike Lee, Republican from
Utah.
He is Ted Cruz without a beard, not quite
as salacious.
He's a little bit more milquetoast, but certainly
an obstructionist, certainly someone who is
whose agenda is marked by his ability to not
vote for things.
That's his that's his his pride and glory.
Is his ability to not vote?
Here's Mike Lee.
Speaker 5: People are still digesting it.
Members of the Senate are still digesting
it.
Look, we're in a period of great inflation
brought on by a period of almost unfettered,
unrestrained federal spending.
It bears no connection, it seems, to the laws
of mathematics or to the amount of money that
were brought in.
This bill would spend a staggering one point
two trillion dollars.
It would be yet another inflation bomb in
an economy that's already been carpet bombed
by other inflation bombs.
If I grasp the fact that it's difficult to
put together a bipartisan package, I have
nothing but respect for each of our colleagues
who were part of this effort.
I also am willing to acknowledge that the
bill does a lot of good things and would help
a lot of deserving beneficiaries.
There are a lot of people who would benefit
in a lot of ways from it, but there is a huge
problem with it.
It is not paid for the reason that we know
that that's a problem, that it's not paid
for.
Is that the one consistent refrain that you
hear from its sponsors, other than the fact
that it's bipartisan, which which we know
and which we respect is the fact that it's
paid for.
They'll say over and over again that this
bill is paid for.
But when you look at the pays, the pay fors,
they don't add up.
When you have papers that don't actually pay,
you're just going to add to the debt and deficit
and this isn't a good time to be doing that.
Speaker 1: It never ceases to amaze me and
never will cease to amaze me.
These Republicans who.
Who pride themselves now on on how is this
going to be paid for?
How are we ever going to pay for those?
We're saddling our children with debt.
As though this is a household and debt means
the same thing as you owning a car and having
credit card debt, it is not the same thing.
But to where was Mike Lee during the Donald
Trump administration that was running up one
and one and a half trillion dollar deficits
while things were good economically in the
country?
Where were you, Mike Lee?
Where were you?
It just rings hollow now listen, I would I
would be lying if I didn't say that I'm a
little nervous about the aggressiveness of
the progressives in Congress, the squad who
I am almost universally a fan of.
But if if they push this too far and we get
nothing and they give the Republicans an excuse.
To back out and not vote for or for whatever
conference agreement they come to on a bill,
then we've lost, then we get nothing.
We don't even get the one or one point two
trillion, we get zero.
And we're back to square one with the infrastructure
week, week after week.
Kind of a situation.
Not good.